start with a cookie dough simply
combined Muscovado sugar peanut butter
and butter until light and fluffy
then add your egg a splash of milk
vanilla seeds and beat again until
smooth
sit together salt baking powder and
flour the mix until thoroughly combined
in floured hands roll the cookie dough
into golf ball sizes flatten and create
an indent with your finger fill with
half jam and half peanut butter place
the cookies on a tray lined with baking
paper and bake in a preheated oven for
10 to 12 minutes cool before serving
[Music]
next chopped main course and my take on
an iconic American salad first made
almost a century ago Caesar salad is
definitely a classic but the trick to
keeping dishes like this modern and
relevant is to tweak them but not lose
what made them brilliant in the first
place here's my version for the ultimate
American lunch my first twist is in the
dressing me the most important part of
the Caesar salad is that dressing rich
creamy slightly spicy begin by making a
basic mayonnaise start off with the egg
yolks then just a little spoon Dijon and
then a little splash of red wine vinegar
start whisking
once you've got that nice slightly
thickened texture drizzle in your olive
oil should fall through your whisk it's
like a nice thick double cream texture
beautiful
now take the Mayo to another level with
anchovies and crush garlic now chop up
the anchovies and the garlic together so
we almost want that to be like a really
nice puree then grated parmesan lemon
juice that will make the dressing
citrusy lighter in color and then a
little splash of water in now
all of a sudden it transforms that
mayonnaise into an amazing delicious
like dressing nice
next job the croutons and I like using
crusty bread for extra crunch and just
dice up your bread season with salt and
pepper then add to a hot pan with olive
oil and fry give that a really nice toss
as the croutons start to turn golden
simply great on a generous amount of
Parmesan cheese you've been rolling
around stop them from sticking together
you got that really nice cheesy
delicious crouton and now they're out
now for the fun job assembling the
Caesar salad
starting with romaine lettuce and don't
slice the lettuce too thinly a squeeze
of lemon on with half of that gutsy and
chubby Mayo dressing saving some to coat
your chicken later then sprinkle half
your croutons give that a really nice
mix salad in it's all beautifully
dressed add the remaining croutons and
finished with a good grating of Parmesan
cheese that for me is a perfect Caesar
salad however I'm gonna take it to
another level and grill a stunning
chicken breast start by preheating your
griddle pan then butterfly your chicken
breast simply slice from the thin end
towards the thick bit of the breast the
knife do the work and literally just
open up
now that's how we butterfly a chicken
breast so therefore it will cook twice
as quick and she asked nice and moist in
the center season the chicken on both
sides with salt and ground pepper lay
your chicken breast onto the grill
never oil the grill and you are
absolutely ready to put your chicken now
[Music]
cook for three to four minutes on each
side until the chickens got those lovely
stripes from the griddle which adds a
gorgeous smoky flavor whilst they rest
spoon over some of the remaining anchovy
dressing the chicken cools down with the
flavor the seasoning of the anchovy the
garlic and a parmesan seeps into that
chicken slice the chicken into strips
where I serve the chicken warm in a
separate bowl so it doesn't wilt a salad
spoon of dressing
furnished out with it will touch with
dressing an American classic
I think we're most popular sellers
anywhere in the world but it's still the
most delicious
[Music]
when it comes to lunch
this really is an American dream a
delicious Caesar salad and succulent
golden griddle chicken with peanut
butter and jam cookies for dessert
[Music]